I reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey if you guys have been paying
its intention to the channel I've been
gone that's yeah so I've did some solo
videos and that's why there's like three
Commons / video that go where's the
other guy they know your problem the
other guy yeah where's Ryan Choi you're
supposed to man down the channel you
totally missed this weird trailer I
wanted to watch it with you
bs you didn't know is out I did any
videos that you guys might have seen
where I was on this week they were
pre-recorded isn't that funny how things
can work that way
what like look Craig was bad like all
these life right you have an editor and
a switchboard TV is not even one friend
[Music]
hey miss Potts Pol Pot was a Cambodian
Communist revolutionary and politician
if you find this recording don't feel
bad about this that is the seventh
studio album by American singer and
songwriter Michael Jackson part of the
journey is the end where they play this
on the end by the doors
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun that sounds adrift is a 2018
film starring Shailene Woodley food
water ran out four days ago I have found
seven hundred billion restaurants in
your nearest area would you like me to
find one okay I'm calling Joe's pizza
for eight pizzas with pepperoni all
appearance today
Pizza time
slow ghosts waiting
[Music]
that's good oh great
[Music]
hell yeah
smoking the reefer got my pants exactly
what he said he was gonna do no crime he
wiped out okay favor sense which is of
all living creatures I missed the part
where that's my problem
we lost how long have you been standing
there staring at me
those friends pay to us family
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
[Music]
I have not here is it
this is waiting for me by the door huh
oh that's right captain
oh wait a minute was this San Lee's
birthday recently
right a bit
that's a good picture of Anton Blake Cox
yeah oh dang
wow it is uses justice but Dave were
filming this is it was yesterday
so two days ago have you guys yeah you
stand on the other side
happy birthday Stan åkesson showing that
support hey you are sexy
[Music]
pretty soon all the YouTube videos will
be on patreon pretty much that's the
future where all its gonna transfer over
everyone's gonna be like if you like us
come to this exclusive feed was curious
to know what aldo was gonna do with this
trailer reported played it I know like
the last minute is dedications to
patrons and stuff and then I was
thinking though how do you make this
more than four minutes because a big
complaint that a lot of people have the
endgame trailer was how they don't show
a lot what was he gonna do to it really
stretch us out you know I always knew he
loves Tobey Maguire spider-man I think
he loves him more than I even realized
oh yeah he's a man after my own heart
that touched me the most out of I think
maybe this has the most Tobey Maguire
heart of any of his weird trailer
because it's not even it's not just dark
Tobey no now it's Pizza Tobey now there
was Toby from the first movie there was
Toby from the first movement yeah oh man
there's just like Toby's all table
spider-man in here Toblerone I want to
meet him just to try to understand what
his fascination is it's like it was
Tarantino's fascination as but feet
that's what Aldo has with the Tobey
Maguire's why not just Tobey which is
specifically the Peter Parker that Tobey
Maguire play there's like a lot of
actual scenes in here like it's full on
bits and jut not just references or and
I like what he's able to naturally
smooth that out like the whole thing
with replacing the Iron Man helmet with
the Alexa keeps talking he says this has
got a new thing or 700 million
restaurants in your area that's probably
what it would be like at that point cuz
you know she'll interrupt you every now
and again when there's a buzz word so
yeah but I love that whole thing with
the sanest being in the Shrek swamp I
never thought of that of like yeah it
kind of looks like that in a way well
yeah I mean I heard the comparisons
between Thanos and Shrek themselves but
yeah even just the location that he's in
you're like he is kind of in a secluded
naturey place that he doesn't probably
want other people to bug him in yeah as
serious and gripping as everything in
The Avengers movies are I'm like with
all the time in the world dish to chill
I got to imagine that hose would be like
walking around naked it's taking long
baths
like that just chillin with a massive
join cuz like at that point this is one
what do you do other than chill out and
enjoy the spoils I imagine you probably
watch a lot of pornographic material I
bet that's all he does
tries to hook up with that girl hi-y
create a new king I thought the door bit
was really funny I didn't recognize the
dead ones I'm Deadpool - maybe I
recognized the panic room lines
specifically but I don't recognize the
moment and I wonder if maybe it's just
because of this distortion and the
recontextualization you guys that keep
something in mind we didn't actually
watch Deadpool - whatever we're in a
spoiler review and all we did was we
watched Chris Stockman Jeremy Jones
double toasted and then we just said
okay what are they saying what's going
on tomatoes or they st. and then we just
made a script out of words salad yeah
you just say what they're saying uh-huh
I've never actually seen a movie we
haven't seen any movies this year no
honestly all I know I have an affinity
Wars because of red letter media yeah
they really broke it down thanks guys
for the reason that to see this that's
why we didn't know what it was yeah
because we don't know movies at all but
the purge was I think my favorite yeah
that's one that blended the best
together and of course a in the bit of
Stan Lee from Civil War I thought it was
a really nice touch a nice homage that
is true though because cap would be a
virgin right I guess I mean he's had
hints of romance with Black Widow Peggy
Carter and all that Bucky but yeah
romance for the Aged ever had
has he I don't think he's ever known the
comforts of a lady I think he is just
abstaining until death that's why he's
so mad the beard funny they actually
forgot that infinity war shot or
something like that and that's the thing
that is everyone has been saying
basically I know it was such a cool
beard well you know he was so depressed
he had to shave absolutely fresh start
yeah literally go through a breakup and
you shave your hair that's
yeah if I control I mean do one very
rash thing to me that funniest joke was
when Ronan cuts off his arm meme that
was always going around was you know
Thor looks like it's about to rap battle
sweaty these move it and I liked how he
didn't go down that route he did
something completely different
hey I'll do great job dude I really
appreciate you doing this man what a
great way to end off the year with a
weird trailer Avengers end game before
we wrap this up I want you to patron the
day shout out to a woman named Rosa
Parra Rosa my ladylove my loves little
Stark woman's dark I miss you I haven't
heard from you in a while but what I do
see is on Instagram you have been
posting a lot of movie reviews a lot of
you know like you do like movie review
blogs and stuff and giveaways if that's
huge you're blowing up on the atmosphere
man that's really cool because I know
when you first
you know joined our patreon page or got
to know John or not you were just a fan
of like movie channels Collider us
mainly John but now to see that you've
taken that inspiration and that love and
have turned it into something where you
have a new hobby on the side that's
really cool
your hard work your mom your hard worker
at your job you got a cool new hobby
that you get a fulfill something you're
passionate about so I think you're in an
off the year quite nicely keep it up I
like reading your love you rose up hey
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation do not subscribe to aldo jones
but pledge to is paid from page we'll
catch you guys later
click notification bells wherever people
[ __ ] say